Ось такою стає Україна.
За різними оцінками, майже шість тисяч сміттєзвалищ і полігонів
займають площу понад10 тисяч гектарів.
Водночас усе це сміття - реальні гроші і реальна енергія.
Експерти порахували, що Україна може економити
майже мільярд кубів газу щороку, виробляючи енергію зі сміття.
Що цьому заважає?
У Держслужбі статистики порахували, що протягом року жителі України
викидають шість з половиною мільйонів тон відходів.
Це приблизно 270 кілограмів на людину.
Одна з головних проблем - це сміття не сортується і як наслідок не переробляється.
І хоча з 1 січня цього рокув Україні заборонено
захоронювати неперероблені побутові відходи,
сортування сміття - більше ініціатива окремих громадян,
ніж загальна практика в межах усієї держави.
У багатьох містах бракує контейнерів для всіх видів відходів.
Нерідко трапляється, що навіть коли люди сортують сміття в окремі мішки,
воно все одно згодом опиняється в одному контейнері.
Бо багатьом двірникам так зручніше - щоб біля смітників не збиралися купи відходів.
Крім того, сміттєпереробні заводи в Україні зацікавлені лише у ресурсоцінному смітті,
зокрема паперовому чи скляному.
Тоді як багато іншого сміття переробляти економічно недоцільно.
Його можна було б спалювати, але в українських умовах і це невигідно.
Експерти стверджують, що теплова енергія, яка б вироблялась на такому заводі,
коштувала б захмарно, порівняно з газом.
Тобто, державі б довелося це дотувати.
І все одно це має перспективу.
У Держагентстві з енергоефективності та енергозбереження порахували,
що з 10 мільйонів тон сміття - це стільки,
скільки продукує приблизно за півтора роки населення України -
можна виробляти понад півтора мільярди гігакалорій теплової енергії.
Це приблизно понад півтора мільярди гривень.
Окрім того - понад два з половиною мільярди кіловат-годин електроенергії щороку.
Це ще 11 мільярдів гривень.
Інвестору це було б цікаво.
Зокрема, електроенергію з біогазу можна було б продавати за підвищеним,
так званим "зеленим", тарифом.
Одне зі слабких місць у цій схемі - вивезення сміття.
Експерти кажуть, потрібно ліцензувати перевізників,
бо країна поступово перетворюється на несанкціоноване сміттєзвалище.
Також стримує розвиток інвестицій у вироблення енергії зі сміття,
як це не парадоксально, відсутність гарантованого обсягу надходження сміття на переробку.
Тобто, сміття багато,
але воно не сортується і мати справу з такими відходами ніхто не хоче.
Крім того, українські заводи воліють брати на переробку лише,
так би мовити, "нове" сміття, яке недовго пролежало на смітнику.
А що робити зі старим, якого на полігонах,
за різними оцінками, понад 12 мільярдів тон, невідомо.